so what I want to do here is make a
video on storm and what I'm hoping is
that at the end of all this you'll have
an understanding of who her character is
as well as how she's changed over the
years now because storms origin comes to
us following her introduction what I
want to do here is jump into her
backstory and then wrap around with her
introduction into Marvel Comics so in
order to pull storms backstory together
we're going to have to draw on four main
sources uncanny x-men issues number 102
and number 117 as well as storms 2005
and 2006 miniseries I'm starting with
her 2006 mini series we learned that her
father a man named David Monroe had
fallen in love and married a princess
from Kenya named nadara due to her love
for David combined with her desire to
see the world nadir moved to New York
with David where they took up residence
in Harlem
however because race relations between
blacks and whites were strained with
violence from whites Ward's blacks
increasing in frequency and the events
leading up to the civil rights movement
by 1951 and Adair had feared for the
safety of herself David and storm and so
six months after the birth of storm the
family moved to Cairo Egypt I'm picking
up with uncanny x-men issue number 102
we learned of following their arrival
the suez crisis broke out now deviating
away from this origin for a second this
instance is one of the reasons why so
many fans loved Chris Claremont the Suez
Crisis was a world world event that took
place in 1956 when Israel France and
Britain launched an invasion of Egypt to
seize control the Suez Canal
while the United Nations had forced him
to withdraw Chris Claremont took this
event and then folded it into the story
during the Suez war sorbs family was
caught in the bombing runs and while her
father had tried to get the family to
safety both he and storms mother were
killed when a plane crashed into their
home and so while storm was eventually
able to dig herself out the emotional
turmoil of her panic combined with
losing her parents
caused storm to develop an extreme case
of claustrophobia now at this point we
transition to uncanny x-men issue number
117 while this is only a very short
scene this actually gives us the first
time storm had met Xavier as well as an
explanation of her life following the
death of her parents
what we learn is that when she was six
years old she had been trained to
operate as an expert thief by a man
named Achmed al-jabbar where we don't
learn much about him initially what
Clement tells us is that storm had been
assigned the task of pickpocketing
Charles Xavier
while storm is successful and stealing
Xavier wallet her actions draw his
attention using his abilities to freeze
her in place Xavier is able to take his
wallet back but draws the attention of a
man named Ahmad Farouk which leads him
down the road to his own origin story
and the basis for starting the x-men
moving over to the 2005 series title
before the storm we learn more about
storm under the tutelage of Achmed al
Jabar what we're told is that Achmed
operated in a fashion similar to Vega in
from the Oliver Twist stories and that
he serves as the mentor of storm among
other children thieves and uses them in
deals with individuals looking to attain
artifacts illegally after meeting with a
man named Barrett Achmed assigned storm
and two others to enter the tomb of
apocalypse and capture an item referred
to as the opal after passing several
booby traps and acquiring the artifact
storm and her group come face to face
with the henchmen of Ozymandias the
immortal stone servant of apocalypse who
transcribed his visions of the past and
the future on stone after defeating the
henchman Ozymandias capture storm but
after realizing who she is from his
visions of the future
Ozymandias explains the storm that she's
actually destined to become an extremely
powerful individual and member of the
x-men in addition to this Ozymandias
tells storm that she'll rise to become
both the savior and a provider for the
people of Kenya which will lead her to
becoming viewed as a God now
transitioning back to storms 2006
miniseries we learned that following her
time with Achmed
storm took up residence with a second
group of fees operating outside of Cairo
in the mountains storm and the other
members of her group would frequently
venture into the city to get supplies
when storms ability to operate as a
thief aquestion by some of her group she
chooses to prove herself by stealing a
camera belonging to a tourist as storms
running away one of the other thieves
knocks her down allowing the man and his
group to gain ground on her however when
he takes him to shoot
storms powers manifest resulting in a
lightning storm in addition to her eyes
glowing bright and fog coming in
following her escape we learned that the
man was actually part of a group that
captures and sells mutants after
retreating back to her village
the man alongside its group arrived
after purchasing information
as to where it was a storm was located
watching an attack against the group the
actions of the man draw the attention of
a young T'Challa while the men are able
to shoot storm with a tranquilizer
T'Challa arrives and begins to fight
them due to his heritage as part of the
Panthers rifle makanda T'Challa
demonstrates exceptional hand-to-hand
combat overcoming the man and knocking
him unconscious
T'Challa takes them back to our group
now the relationship that forms between
T'Challa and storm following their first
encounter is of stupendous importance
here the reason why is that while the
two of them share private moments with
one another and eleven chily forms storm
views yourself as the opposite of what
the child deserves and storms eyes she
hails from the lowest caste of society a
person with no family no wealth and a
past mired in acts as she deemed
necessary but is not really proud of
T'Challa however is a prince hailing
from a family with a strong heritage of
Black Panthers and incredible wealth and
so while the two do share a love for one
another their roads inevitably lead them
down separate paths for their lives
T'Challa would go on to become black
panther and storm would go on to become
a member of the x-men
so again rapping this ordinance story
back around stall initially appeared in
giant-size x-men issue number one and
was created by artist David Cockrum as
part of the new Marvel lineup in an
effort to relaunch the brand as we
discussed in previous videos the x-men
series understand Lee and Jack Kirby had
not achieved a level of success as other
publications while some may say this was
due to a lack of adequate storytelling
others point to the fact that the Marvel
community already had established teams
in the form of the Avengers and the
Fantastic Four regardless of the reasons
for the lackluster sales however the
title was canceled with issue number 93
and i-275 an under editor-in-chief for
Thomas was relaunched the same year
using a more diverse lineup to this end
where giant-size x-men saw the
introduction of characters like Colossus
and Wolverine it also saw the
introduction of storm in an interview
with Blizzard magazine in 1993 titled
how a typhoon blew and success
David Cochrane had stated that initially
storm was a combination of two
characters the first was typhoon who was
a villain largely associated with
Hercules of the Olympians and the second
was Felicia Hardy a notable villainous
of spider-man Peter Parker establishes
of being with the power to manipulate
hurricanes and tornadoes they recall
chram sought to combine and expand the
elemental abilities of typhoon into the
physical appearance of black cod to
produce a male hero
however because Marvel was looking to
break away from the tradition of all
male superhero teams Roy Thomas had
David Cochrane modify his creation into
a woman who could become part of the new
x-men lineup following this and with
Chris Claremont headlining the series
Marvel wasted no time establishing the
fact that storm was not only a powerful
force in Marvel Comics but a strong lead
for young female readers the reason for
this was that at the time women and
african-americans and comments were
really depicted in strong leadership
roles Susan storm was considered the
First Lady of Marvel Comics but she
largely operated second to Reed Richards
as opposed to being an equal in truth
the only real characters level had as
lead african-americans of their comics
where Luke Cage and Black Panther and
while young black men found these heroes
identifiable young black women were
still left out when storm was introduced
she had basically changed all that not
only was she a powerful black woman in
comics under Chris Claremont
she was also placed into a leadership
role an uncanny x-men issues number 138
and 100
thirty nine following to perceive death
of Jean Grae Claremont Road cyclops out
of the x-men team and introduced storm
and his place to operate as a leader
with the same publication seeing the
introduction of Kitty Pryde storms role
as head of the x-men team was expanded
beyond the role of a field leader to a
more personal level when she became
involved in cutie Pie's life by teaching
her the ins and outs of what it means to
be a woman as well as how to deal with a
world that disliked mutants now touching
back on a role as a fuel commander her
ability to lead the team effectively was
best demonstrated in uncanny x-men
issues 269 through 270 and a story
titled this angel fallen considering on
storm following angels kidnapping at the
hands of Morlocks the story saw storm
leading Colossus Kitty Pryde and
Nightcrawler into the tunnels below New
York to rescue Warren Worthington the
coming face to face with Callisto the
Morlock leader storms physical and
character strength was demonstrated in
her ability to overcome Callisto in a
battle to the death as well as allow the
Morlocks to maintain their autonomy as a
society unto themselves while future
stories like to have and have not an
uncanny x-men issue number 173 would see
storm dawn a new look with a mohawk and
leather a major focal point of her
character was a feeling of being split
between her role as a member of the
x-men and replaces leader of her people
in Kenya this element of her character
was fleshed out further by Chris
Claremont over a series of background
stories an uncanny x-men issues 253 267
which saw her traveling back to Africa
but also saw the introduction of gambit
while I wouldn't see her return to Kenya
as a leader in this story storm was
de-aged by a villain known as the nanny
seeking to use the world's mutant
children as an army and while storm was
able to overpower nanny her mind was
wiped of all of her memories appearing
in Cairo and unintentionally causing a
thunderstorm that lasted several days
the storm was discovered by emergency
crews and hospitalized escaping the
hospital due to her fear of not knowing
where she was storm reverted back to her
life of thieving on the streets of Cairo
drawing the attention of the Shadow King
a multiversal representation of
humanity's darker nature the Shadow King
sought to use storms vast abilities to
manipulate the weather in an effort to
conquer the world pursuing and cornering
her in the midst of a robbery the story
saw the introduction of gambit who
happened to be robbing the same house
helping storm to escape the Shadow King
and his van
that you began a friendship that would
actually see so I'm advocating for
gambit to be allowed to become part of
the x-men team now toward the end of
Chris Clemons run a night study one
going forward with the launch of x-men
vol 2
the storms popularity had reached a
fever pitch and with the removal of the
original x-men team as the lineup of X
Factor in the reintroduction into the
current x-men roster Marvel split the
group in half with storm leading the
blue team composed of Jean Grey Colossus
Bishop Archangel and Nightcrawler
however as the 1990s turn into the 2000s
the popularity of the x-men was
beginning to wane then whilst Chris
Claremont would return to the series in
2001 under the moniker of extreme x-men
the title was unable to regain his
former glory
as a result under the direction of Joe
Quesada Marvel initiated the House of M
event in an effort to consolidate the
mutant population reduce its number and
focus on more character-driven stories
the because storm was such a popular
character in comics Marvel had her
keeper ability to manipulate the weather
and unoriginal Hudlin folded her
character over into the black panther
series and introduced their marriage as
two of Marvel's most prominent black
characters the marriage between black
panther and storm actually received
mixed reviews from fans where some
thought it made sense others thought it
was simply thrown in as a publicity
stunt to pull in black readers as the
marriage coincided with the events of
civil war ultimately though the doom and
gloom crowd went out when Marvel
annulled the marriage during the events
of Avengers vs. x-men as I was explained
as when the Phoenix force returned in
pursuit of Hope Summers it was attacked
by Iron Man and Hank Pym looking to see
the Phoenix force destroyed it was
actually split into five pieces each one
merging with Emma Frost Cyclops Colossus
namer and magic while the story would
continue on with the existence of the
Phoenix five during the conflict name of
the Submariner juices powers over his
portion of the Phoenix force to attack
and destroy Wakanda because storm had
previously allied herself with the x-men
in an effort to stab the Phoenix five
after learning of wakanda's destruction
she returned only to be told by Black
Panther that all the x-men had been
branded as enemies of Wakanda and that
their marriage had been annulled
following this both Black Panther and
storm fans were absolutely livid the
reason being because not only had the
marriage appear to be a publicity stunt
but
than doing something to drive interest
in the marriage what Hall simply killed
it off over the course of a single page
for many fans storms pass was mired and
failed relationships and when the
opportunity to find happiness presented
itself Marvel wrote the marriage out of
existence furthermore Black Panther fans
had enjoyed the fact that T'Challa had
always been written in a manner that
depicted honor and courage but when
Wakanda was destroyed the honor
encouraged fans would come to expect was
turned to anger and spite
now following the end of the mirrors
between storm and black panther storm
would go on to be featured as part of
Jason Aaron's amazing x-men as well as a
13-part crossover series from the
guardians of the galaxy the amazing
x-men and nova titled black vortex but
due to the secret Wars event and the
Reformation of the Marvel multiverse
storm appears to be one of the many
heroes that died during the incursion
between earth-616 and the Ultimate
Universe with that being said we're
going to bring this video to an end I
hope you guys enjoyed it and I will
catch you guys later peace